simult main obstacle to that is actually
it's not it's not happening well in the
north you you said that you've destroyed
this Hadith and this Ayah came to my
mind and it was so
profound it can be L it's the first odd
night brothers and sisters at Sal plus
we are trying to teach thousands of
people to learn how to do with do to
learn how to pray Salah to learn f with
new Quran project guys I am a volunteer
and trustee in this organization I can
testify and put my neck on the line that
I trust the brothers behind it we want
to teach thousands we want to open Salah
hubs all around England wh Scotland
Ireland Europe and teach people how to
pray Salah we've got we're printing
guided prayer mats 20,000 of them if
you're watching this guys please donate
whatever you can1 can teach 10 to 30
people how to playay Salah please go to
the link in the description and donate
now
inam brothers and sisters and dear
friends when I saw this interview with
this Satan this scum bastard the killer
of all these pal men women and children
may Allah destroy him in this life and
Hereafter this Hadith and this Ayah came
to my mind and it was so profound as if
like I was looking at him and that was
coming to my mind let's watch this
interview between CNN which I can't
believe CNN the way they stuck it on him
you know this literally made him go
silence zip he had nothing to say and
indeed Allah is going to make him
silence on y we're going to read and
Ayah which you're going to be blown away
here is the
interview
why won't you allow more food trucks to
drive through the border crossings into
Gaza to feed starving civilians while
you continue to take out the terrorists
in Hamas the problem isn't getting the
trucks in the problem is that once
they're getting in they're looted by
Hamas or looted by gangs simultaneous
the main obstacle to that is actually
it's not it's not happening well in the
north you you said that you've destroyed
Hamas if Hamas isn't in in the North how
is Hamas taking away food and if you
open up more border crossings and give
more food into the into the uh into the
area allow starving people to eat uh the
Looting maybe would subside that's human
nature
no so guys Subhan Allah you saw that
absolute Liars these dirt scumbags who
have killed and massacred men women and
children lying that hamus is stealing
food they just want to commit an
outright genocide they are trying to
erase the population of Gaza and you are
messing with a group of people that got
Allah behind them Subhan Allah you see
how he went silent do you know what it
made me think you know when he went
silent it's as if his body language and
his body his filthy scumbag body was
speaking guilt was coming out like yeah
I'm a I'm a liar you know when look at
someone and they don't talk and you know
their facial expression the way they
move their hands the way they they move
their head the way they looking down Etc
it says so much there's a of the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him he says on a
man will be brought forward Allah will
bring a man to account and he this man
will come and say oh Allah I believe in
you your Messengers your books your
prophets I did good deeds I fasted etc
etc and then Allah say enough enough you
have spoken we are now going to bring
our Witnesses against you and he will
say to Allah oh Allah who will be a
witness against me yes who could be cuz
these are things that I did but nobody
saw and he will say indeed Allah will
say we have our Witnesses and the man
arrogantly will say I only accept myself
as a witness and Allah says the angels
and yourself will be a witness enough
for you and you know what will happen
his mouth will be made to shot silence
he cannot speak and his limbs his limbs
like the scum bastard Netanyahu that's
Massac
scumbag his limbs like we saw in that
interview talking to us this guilt was
coming out his limbs will be made that
day his limbs will be made that day to
speak and they will testify that he was
a liar this man in this Hadith they will
testify against him and they will speak
and do you know what that will happen
afterwards do you know what will happen
afterwards brother and sisters Subhan
Allah you are going to be shocked just
imagine this guy yeah and not only that
what does the Ayah say there's ay in the
Quran chapter 36: 65 today Allah says we
will seal their mouths their hands will
speak to us and their feet will testify
to us what they used to commit and that
man that they will say wo unto you after
yes he let to speak he will speak his
Limbs and say woe unto you for I was
trying to protect you from the fire can
you imagine he was speak to his limbs he
was saying I was only lying to protect
you from the fire now we going to go to
the fire and he's he's blaming his Limbs
and they will say Allah the almighty
he's the one who that may he's the one
that made this speak and he will enter
the fight and this is about a person who
is aaic the scholar say not somebody
who's a Believer he was a maaf a liar he
believed in his heart anyone that anyone
that doesn't believe in their heart but
testify on their tongue yeah we believe
we believe in the prophet is a maaf
anyone that believes in the heart Islam
is true and they do not testify they're
a cfir and anyone that believes in the
heart and testify in the tongue is a
Believer they is Lay
it can be sorry it can be is the first
odd night brothers and sisters at Sal
plus we are trying to teach thousands of
people to learn how to do to learn how
to pray Salah to learn with new Quran
project guys I am a volunteer and
trustee in this organization I can
testify and put my neck on the line that
I trust the brothers behind it we want
to teach thousands we want to open Salah
hubs all around England Wales Scotland
Island Europe and teach people how to
pray Salah we've got we're printing
guided pray M 20,000 of them if you're
watching watching this guys please
donate whatever you can1 can teach 10 to
30 people how to pray Salah how to do
and read the Quran F memorize ,000 can
teach 100 to 300 people to learn how to
do to learn how to play Salah and
inshallah brother sisters to uh learn
Surah fa please go to the link in
description and donate now inallah